Your move.
Governor DeSantis.
I'm Michael Smerconish in Philadelphia.
Friday, Attorney General Merrick Garland
appointed a special counsel
regarding the federal investigations
into the events of January six
and Donald Trump's holding on
to presidential records at Mar a Lago.
Here's how he explained the move
based on recent developments
including the former
president's announcement
that he is a candidate
for president in the next election.
And the sitting president
stated intention
to be a candidate as well.
I have concluded that it is
in the public interest
to appoint a special counsel.
Trump
then responded during a keynote speech
at the America
First Gala at Mar a Lago,
calling it an appalling announcement
and a horrendous abuse of power.
They want to do bad things
to the greatest movement
in the history of our country,
but in particular bad things to me.
But I've gotten used to it.
It's lucky.
A lot of people wouldn't get used to it
so easily.
This is a rigged deal, just as the 2020
election was rigged,
and we can't let them get away with it.
So what could all of this mean
for the 2024
race and Trump's potential leading
rival, Ron DeSantis?
Trump had just made his intention
to run
official Tuesday night,
just one week
after an underwhelming performance
by Republicans in the midterms.
One bright spot for the GOP the 20 point
landslide victory
by Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
that despite Trump nicknaming him
Ron de sanctimonious,
that was a shot across DeSantis
Bow, a
warning of the rough
and tumble world
of being a Donald Trump opponent.
Soon, DeSantis is going to have to decide
what he wants to do.
He's only 44.
The question is
whether the next election
is his best shot.
You know, strike while the iron is hot.
Ask any Paul and they'll cite
two examples of candidates
at similar crossroads
with vastly different outcomes.
Barack Obama
in 2008 Chris Christie in 2012.
Remember many scoffed
at the junior senator from Illinois
when he announced
his presidential campaign
shortly after being elected to the U.S.
Senate.
But Obama caught lightning in a bottle
and the rest is history.
Then there's Chris Christie
the Tough-Talking
former prosecutor was elected
governor of New Jersey
in an upstart campaign
against incumbent Jon Corzine in 2009.
Christie was Trump before Trump.
Relishing his boardwalk
face to face confrontations
with Garden State detractors
while Christie contemplated
running for president in 2012
against Obama.
His decision, of course
came before the reported hug
between the two
at the time of Superstorm Sandy.
Instead, Christie opted to burnish
his gubernatorial credentials
while running up the score
in his reelection.
Christie was reelected,
but his fortunes quickly turned.
Anyone remember the George W?
The George Washington Bridge
closure scandal?
Soon after morning, Consult
found that
Christie had the worst disapproval
of any American governor.
By his last day in office,
his approval rating stood at 14%
And when he did eventually run
for the presidency in 2016
he placed
sixth in the New Hampshire primary
and then dropped out of the race.
No doubt DeSantis is studying the Obama
and Christie playbooks
and trying to figure out
which model matches
his current situation.
And DeSantis calculus
is complicated by the presence
of Donald Trump.
Early polling
commissioned by the Club for Growth
shows that DeSantis
handily beats
Trump in critical early states.
DeSantis leads Trump by 11
percentage points in Iowa
by 15 points in New Hampshire.
He leads
Trump by 26 points in Florida
and 20 points in Georgia.
But that's head to head with Trump.
And there's no guarantee
that DeSantis gets Trump alone
one on one.
Remember back in 2016,
Trump was able to win the nomination
because he had a relatively small
but loyal group of supporters
at a very crowded debate stage.
I remember being at the Reagan Library
for the second GOP
debate of the 2016 cycle
There were 15 candidates,
so many on that debate stage
that it had to be split in two.
The more the merrier for Donald Trump,
but not for Ron DeSantis.
As he decides
whether to run for president in 2024.
DeSantis has to be worried about more
than just the size of the field.
The only venue for a fight with Donald
Trump is a steel cage.
DeSantis might win the battle
and lose the war.
There's no guarantee
that if you beat Trump, he embraces you.
Trump's for Trump.
Not for a party. Not for an ideology.
It's hard to envision
DeSantis vanquishing
Trump,
but still gaining
his endorsement thereafter.
Remember Trump's a guy who trashed
presidential protocol
and refused to attend
Joe Biden's inauguration.
He relishes burning down the house.
Just ask
Georgia senators
David Perdue and Kelly Loeffler.
So DeSantis has to consider
that he could enter the race,
get Trump in a small field and beat him.
Big ifs
only to have Trump trash him
after the nomination is settled
and tank
the general election
to the benefit of Democrats.
Maybe the better course is to sit it out
and wait for another cycle
Or maybe he should call Chris Christie.
Joining me now to discuss is Gary
Final, who writes the Florida playbook
for Politico.
Gary also just wrote this piece.
Gary,
what are your thoughts
in terms of how the Merrick Garland
announcement impacts DeSantis timeline?
Well, I'm not really sure it will.
I mean, obviously,
there's a lot
going on there
and we'll see where all that plays out.
It's my understanding that DeSantis,
for the most part, the timeline is if
it is when a decision is made,
it would be made sometime
probably in the late spring
after the next legislative session
here in Florida.
So I'm not sure this is going
to immediately impact that timeline.
They've got a transition to a deal
where they've got an inauguration
and then sort of the
the upcoming session
in which
I would anticipate that
the Florida legislature will again
be called upon to do things to sort of,
you know, help,
you know, brandish his name
you have written that
all signs
make it appear likely that he does run.
What's the basis for that opinion?
Well, I think item
number one
is he's sitting on a lot of money.
He he raised a probably
what may be a record
for a gubernatorial candidate in America.
And he basically
they didn't have to spend all of it.
I think that
last count probably
about 70 to 80 million that
And I know there are some questions
as to legally how you do all this
and the hurdles and everything like that.
But 70 80 million
that could be transferred
over to a super PAC
at some point in time.
That's item number one.
You know,
and then when we talk about the timeline,
you were talking about the whole Christie
Obama thing.
I understand that,
you know, he just got reelected.
So let's just do the math.
We have term limits in Florida.
So basically he would leave office in 26.
So if he
if he waited, he would be out of office.
For two years.
And, you know, the thing about it
is, is that having
the governorship
is a good place to get a lot of attention
and media attention
and in other things like that.
So you just wonder how we how
it would be.
I mean, a thing about,
you know,
Jeb Bush,
he was one of the ones
who was vanquished by Trump.
He'd been office out of office
for about eight years.
And even though he raised a lot of money
for that race, it's
sort of like
he had been out of the picture.
Now, two years is
obviously different than eight, but
but it's it's something to consider.
He hasn't taken the bait so far.
Right.
The sanctimonious.
There was no respond in kind.
Does that surprise you?
No.
No, I think well, I
we had a story a few days ago
in which we quoted somebody,
a consultant,
who said there's
there's sort of a thinking about,
well, maybe Donald will punch itself out
that you know,
they're not going to respond.
Now, you did see that he's taken
sort of these
these he's made comments
without responding
directly to the insults.
He's basically said,
you know, just the other day
when somebody asked him
point blank about Trump,
he said something about,
well, you know, I'm going to focus on
what I'm doing, but,
you know, what we're doing in
Florida is working.
Look at the scoreboard.
And he was telling in another time,
he said, you know what,
people just need to chill
out about all of this. So
I think that he
you know, I think that they're sort of
in a standpoint where,
you know,
they've just come off a very large
win, a win.
They gave him
super majorities in the legislature.
There's going to be those
who who feel that the Republican
takeover of Congress
is in no small part to Ron DeSantis
because it was his administration
that pushed forward a map
that netted Republicans
four seats in Congress.
Now, that map is being litigated
and there's those
who say it is unconstitutional.
But we'll see.
But for now,
he's got all these wins
that he can point to
as he moves into into next year.
You're closer to it.
My hunch
is that he
probably wants to keep his powder dry
and hope that Merrick Garland
or the special counsel
do some of his work for him.
Gary, thank you, as always.
We appreciate your insights.